There have been many brilliant minds who have lent their talents,
the committing and the solving of crime,
but none stands as supremely as that of Sherlock Holmes with is unequaled.
Powers of reasoning deduction and scientific application homes was able to solve
the cases that are baffled the best of Scotland Yard with his tweed suit cloth
cap and his black clay pipe.
The world's greatest sleuth has become familiar to a new generation through
television and movie adaptations of his many adventures in this week's by
graphics.
We have dug deep to uncover the private world of the notoriously secretive Mr
Sherlock Holmes may well have been the greatest detective living or dead is to
investigate the criminal minds,
but he was an extremely private genius as a result of the study of his early
years as an exercise in frustration for biographies.
On one of the few occasions that he did open up about his family origins.
He mentioned to his ever loyal sidekick,
James Watson,
that his ancestors were country squires who up here to have that much the same
life as it's natural to people of that class.
He also revealed that his grandmother was the sister of Mlg,
Horace Vernay,
the renowned French artist who specialized in the military paintings.
His final familiar revelation was that he had an older brother,
Mycroft,
who according to show lock in self possessed even greater powers of deduction
than he did.
Apart from those few tidbits,
we are left to work out the details of homes,
his early life from circumstantial evidence and deduction.
Something of a coincidence I might think.
Holmes was born and raised in the county of Sussex on the south coast of
England.
The homeless family seat was that Linford,
a few miles from portion sherlock's.
Father,
a gentleman named roderick homes was born around 18,
15.
Roderick was a man's man who delighted in such outdoor pursuits as fox hunting,
trout fishing and pheasant shooting in sharp contrast to his two sons.
He didn't put much credence in book learning and affairs of the minds.
Shallock's mother was 13 years younger than her husband's Charlotte.
Aircraft came from Lancashire,
but origins were French from her mother's to see all their names.
She inherited not only artistic leanings,
but a flighty self-absorbed personality.
The marriage,
it was not a happy one,
and with such disparate personalities,
it could be said that it was doomed from the start.
Their first child was born in 18,
46 and given the name of John Microsoft homes,
the name gives us an insight into the state of the parent's mental processes.
Roderick hated his own name and wanted to give his firstborn son a plane on
complicated name,
but Charlotte has quite the opposite view.
She wanted to name that was different,
striking and memorable.
Of course,
Roderick one,
Charlotte managed to squeeze her choice and Amalgam of possessive nature,
my with the last syllable of her maiden name cropped in as a middle name.
It was only because he spends more of his formative years around his possessive
mother that the boy came to be known as Mycroft a name which grated on his
father.
Every time he heard it,
it took Roderick and Charlotte seven years to produce another child's no
surprise considering the deteriorating state of their union.
By now,
roderick has given up entirely on trying to control his wife's autistic or as he
sort irrational site.
He left anything up to her and she even out did a creativity the first time
around,
she named a second son,
Sherlock.
The name wasn't entirely her own invention in order to escape from the
increasing abuse of our husbands who had taken more and more to the bottle,
she began making trips to London where she would visit art galleries and theater
performances.
She became enamored with a father and son,
pair of English artists,
both who were named William Sherlock in the hopes that our seconds would prove
to be a great artist.
She gave him the Monica Sherlock
was the customer of the day to send sons away to boarding school.
Roderick didn't believe in higher education,
and so the two brothers endured a succession of tutors,
some of whom were good,
while others were terrible,
even when they did have a good teacher.
Now,
volatile environments cost by the parents losing for one another did not make
for conductive learning.
However,
Microsoft and sherlock educated themselves,
despite their environments,
it seemed became apparent that both boys were brilliant.
Sherlock instantly fell in love with books later referring to himself as an
omnivorous reader.
His brother,
meanwhile,
was obsessed with numbers even though there was a seven year gap in age,
the two boys were extraordinarily close.
They drew up on each other for mutual support and mental stimulation,
Microsoft periods,
or an overweight child.
You avoided any type of exercise or physical exertion.
Instead in his early teens,
he became fascinated with electricity and chemistry.
This soon caught the attention of his younger brother.
He began saving as pocket money to buy scientific Kratos shut look,
escapes the unpleasant environments at home.
By finding interests outside the house,
he developed a friendship with a man who was in charge of his father's hunting
house.
This man named Sherman was a taxidermist and shell expense many hours watching
him at work.
The boy also spends a lot of time in his father's stables.
Rate.
Develops a great acquiring knowledge.
Unlike his brother,
Sherlock,
enjoyed sports.
He became a talented young boxer winning a number of matches against local boys.
Roderick,
during his sober periods,
tried his best,
send the boys into country.
Squire's,
though they both became possible shots with fouling pieces.
Neither of them had any stomach for fox hunting.
Furthermore,
Mycroft was a poor horse rider.
One Constellation for Roderick though was that they both took to fishing.
What they really relished was the consultative nature of the activity,
which provided plenty of time for planning overall.
However,
Roderick was disappointed in how his sons were turning out,
unsurprisingly then he very rarely showed them any affection,
preferring to cast aspirations on their manhood and their physical prowess.
This lack of physical display was more than compensated for by Charlotte who
would shower the boys with hugs and kisses at every opportunity.
This only served to further strengthen roderick's conviction that he had raised
a couple of cities when our sons were old enough.
Charlotte took them to London where she introduced them to concerts and opera
and guided them through the picture galleries of the metropolis.
The brothers found out chatter,
tiresome and their behavior sometimes embarrassing,
but they were grateful to get away from their father.
As a result of these London visits,
shallow developed a strong love of music.
This inspired Charlotte to hire a violin teacher for the boy,
but the lessons they didn't last long.
When Roderick found out about it,
he put an immediate stop to the lessons Mycroft and Charlotte Gossett and spends
a lot of time with other boys in the community.
They found them not to be up to their intellectual level,
and so I've spent most of their time together.
However,
they did make one great friends and that would be Charles Edward Howard.
Vincent Charles was the son of Sir Frederick Vincent Rector of the parish of
slim fit.
This boy was just as brilliant as the homes boys.
He was sent off to boarding school at age 12 that spends most of his time during
the school vacations in the company of Mycroft and Sherlock Charles Howard.
Vincent winds onto four j distinguished multifaceted Korea,
which fills two pages in Britain's dictionary of national biography.
Roderick refused to send his oldest son to university when Microsoft reached the
age of 20,
but by now the older brother had enough of his father's abusive ways and team
moved to London where he secured a position as an assistant to a member of
parliaments.
When his brother moved away.
Sherlock was 13 years of age.
He spent an unhappy few years as a loner in an unhappy household,
is only bright spots being the regular letters that he received from his brother
in London and surprisingly at age 18,
Sharla convinced his father to send them to Cambridge University.
During his first semester,
he was invited by a fellow students by the name of Victor Trevor to spends the
vacation with him that his family's estate and Norfolk not jeans.
You returned to his fueling parents.
He gladly accepted the invitation following this visit.
Sherlock did not return home for future holidays,
but took rooms in London where he buried himself in chemical research.
He had his mind set on becoming a chemical analyst while the university homes
played no part in team sports which would have required cooperation with others.
Instead,
he focused on boxing.
The only friends he had at college was Victor,
trevor,
just as the only friends he had as an adult was Dr Watson
in the autumn of 18,
74 shallow to be on his third year of study at Cambridge,
but he left before the year was out.
With no degree.
The details have never been revealed,
but it is clear that some sort of trauma afflicted,
both sherlock and Mycroft during these months and left psychological wounds on
both of them.
Biographers have speculated that the situation may have involved members of the
opposite sex.
Dr Watson later shed some light on the homes mindset.
His aversion to women and is disinclination to form new friendships were very
typical of his unemotional character,
but not more so than his complete suppression of every reference to his own
people.
Homes himself once said,
I am not a whole sold admirer of womankind.
Women are never to be entirely trusted,
not the best of them.
Despite this homes was always courteous and considerate to women,
is hostility to the other.
Sex was confined to the areas of love and marriage,
so whatever the precise nature of this emotional blow,
it resulted in sherlock being a lifelong user of narcotics.
This addiction was in sharp contrast to his temperance and otherwise clean mode
of living at the time the use of narcotics in Britain was neagle still have.
It was alarming to Dr Watson.
He wanted more than one occasion,
tried to reason with the great detective,
but it was a mind of destroying completely wasteful and individual practice.
Homes usually brushed him off about it over the years,
but with Watson's help,
he was able to have limited success in shaking off the habits whether the tragic
events was separate to the death of homes.
As parents is not clear,
those passings surely would have been horrific in themselves.
They have in the autumn of 18,
74 when Microsoft was in London and Shallow Cambridge.
On hearing the news,
both boys returned immediately to Sussex.
That father had been killed by a pistol,
shot to the head of their mother,
had been strangled.
The police immediately ruled out murder suicide,
but Microsoft in sherlock knew better.
A lonely and depressed Charlotte,
but found release in the arms of another man.
I'm discovering the affair.
Roger.
He had strangled his wife in a frenzy and then stagger to the stables where you
attend the pistol on himself.
The two sons.
Did you still have this room,
a capital examination of the scene coupled with that inside knowledge of the
state of their parents' marriage,
the man who had been the subject of Charlotte's affection,
and therefore the indirect cause of the tragedy was a man of privilege by the
name of Lord Tap Clinton.
He discretes the left the area after the deaths,
but his actions left a deep seated resentments of titles,
men in the heart of Sherlock,
this family tragedy,
his homes at the age of 20.
I left him with a deep seated business against his mother,
apart from his brother.
She was the only person who had ever shown him love and affection and from all
of this,
what he decided he needed was a complete change of scenery
from earliest boyhood.
SHELLAC had been fascinated with the American west.
They wanted to travel to America and payers way for some time,
so mycroft advanced him some money from his father's estate.
He left for the new world in early 18,
75.
When he arrived in New York.
He became fascinated by the theater scene in Manhattan.
It provided the escape that he needed.
In fact,
he loved the scene so much that he drifted into a theatrical troupe in the
autumn of [inaudible] 75 because Victorian society in America,
as well as in England,
considered acting less than reputable occupation homes,
chose not to tarnish his family,
named by calling himself Mr Sherlock.
After a brief running in Manhattan,
the three went on tour that took them as far as Chicago.
Those Korea on the American stage lasted for less than a year.
Homes found the work absorbing and soon became adept at the professional skills
of makeup and disguise.
Disability benefited him greatly and later cases where he recreated himself into
everything from an Italian priest to an old woman
to obtain realistic details for the working class and criminal roles.
He played on stage homes ventured into dangerous neighborhoods in New York and
other cities.
That is true visitors.
There's often proved hazardous,
requiring the cooperation of the local police.
These excursions also gave homes,
contacts,
and information that he was able to draw on during his later professional
career.
As he followed police investigations in the cities he was touring.
He began to realize the practical value of the scientific knowledge.
You had gains from his boyhood experiments and his cambridge education,
bloodstains poisons mud caked on shoes,
liquid left in glasses,
his scientific way of looking at such as revealed forensic evidence,
which he was able to pass on to the police for the first time.
He began to seriously consider taking up detective work professionally.
He imagined himself something entirely new to the Victorian era,
a scientific detective.
This motive was to power him through the rest of his life.
After 18 months of traveling around,
the United States almost decided it was time to return to the country of his
birth on resends in London.
He founds lodging just around the corner from the British Museum.
He began running errands for private detectives carrying out such distasteful
duties as gathering evidence for divorce cases,
but all the while he was picking up the basics of detective work to further this
work.
He revived his study of science with a focus on chemistry,
botany,
and anatomy
offer a year also,
Hamza was ready to branch off and start his own detective agency.
His first cases were domestic and routine revolving around minus civil disputes.
He walked onto cultivate his relationship with the police,
passing on information that would help them crack a case in return.
The police past clients onto him the year 18,
88 was a fortunate one for Sherlock Holmes.
Scans will have left the London police in a situation that then they were open
to the up and coming to tax if the case which has become known as the musgrave
ritual was his first high profile case establishing his superior powers of
deduction ends for us to investigation to a fascinated public case.
Got underway when Holmes was cooled by a university,
Acquaintance Reginald Musgrave to have musgraves domestic staff had disappeared
following their dismissal for reading a secret family documents,
calls of the musgrave ritual items not only solve the case,
but uncovered the crown of Kenny Charles the fest which had been missing for 200
years as a result of the fame garnered from the musgrave ritual homes was
invited to give a series of lectures to instruct the newly formed criminal
investigation department.
Won't cid the brilliance.
Twenty four year old now found himself in lightening hard bitten Korea cops on
anatomy,
chemistry and botany.
He also,
at this point,
knew enough about geology to identify soil on clothing and shoes
and
more and more detectives now goes into the habits of consulting with homes when
they reached an impasse in their investigations,
even though they hated to admit this,
the young Pii would invariably provide them with the breakthrough that they
needed in order to crack a case.
In 18,
81 homes began lodging with a man who would become inextricably tied to himself.
Dr John Watson.
The address was two t one b Baker Street Watson was a young medic who had just
returned from Afghanistan and was looking for a cheap place to live on the first
meeting.
Once it was fascinated that homes deduced that he had recently been in
Afghanistan without him having profit.
That information from that moment on Watson was perks,
fares part home seemed delighted to share his home with the affable Dr Watson,
the two men would go onto for the partnership that has been an equals in the
annals of criminal investigation as same as his reputation grew.
He attracted more and more affluent clients and was able to charge higher fees.
These hyphae cases subsidized others in which he helps people who could only pay
a small fee or no fee at all.
He wants,
says that the status of my clients is of less interest to me than the interest
of his case.
What he was after,
what cases that challenged him.
His greatest challenge came and his ongoing hunt for London's master criminal
Professor Moriarty.
In order to avoid Moriarty's criminal organization.
Holmes was forced to flee Europe in late 18,
91,
but the criminal masterminds pursued the great detective and it's a climactic
struggle occurred.
Top Theater Reichenbach falls in Switzerland.
It appears that both men fall to their death and the funeral is held for the
world's greatest detective.
However,
homes,
his body was never recovered and indeed he was not.
Debt for three years,
though he allowed the world,
including Dr Watson to believe that he was dead.
This period is known by biographers as the great hiatus in 18,
94.
He was suddenly back on the scene explaining to a bewildered Dr Watson that he
had faked his death to get moriarty's henchmen off his back.
Ten years later,
homes retard to a small farm in Sussex downs where he took up beekeeping in
1908.
He came out of retirement in order to aid his governments working as a double
agents.
He masterminded the capture of a German spike.
It is believed he kept busy with intelligence work during the first world war.
There is no record of homes is activities after the war.
So when did Sherlock Holmes die?
The answer is obvious.
Just consider the Plethora of TV shows,
movies,
and books on the man and he will surely agree that Sherlock Holmes had never
died,
just as he had never lived.
Sherlock Holmes.
He's a complete work of fiction,
the creation of a writer by the name of Arthur Conan doyle.
That's if you've spent the last 20 minutes believing that you are learning the
history of a real life human being,
you're certainly not alone.
In a recent poll,
21 percent of respondents thought that the greatest sleuth of Baker Street
really did exist,
which just goes to show that sometimes fiction is stranger than truth.
That's you might notice that this video is published on April first April fools
to everybody,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday wouldn't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race
and as always,
thank you for watching.